for these children this was the
highlight of a difficult 2022 and this
year shows little sign of improvement
most have been forced from their homes
for fear of airstrikes and artillery
attacks
but as the gifts are handed out the
smiles return bags of snacks and Cake a
rare Indulgence in difficult times
I've seen children with trauma because
of the sounds of warplanes and artillery
they won't speak to strangers because
they're so scared when they draw I see
pictures of guns and abandoned homes the
appearance are too busy trying to earn a
living and can't take care of them these
eight handouts are all funded from
donations within Myanmar International
organizations can't operate because of
fighting and restrictions put in place
by myanmar's military
I see malnutrition amongst the children
there are grown-ups and elderly people
who aren't getting enough to eat and
they have problems maintaining their
personal hygiene because they've been
forced out of their homes
in another Camp close to the city of
demoso women do their laundry in the
pools above a waterfall
an estimated 75 percent of the people in
this state have been forced from their
homes by fighting basic facilities like
running water and electricity have
stopped working
even the journey to school is now an
adventure these high school students
must row across a river in a Dugout
canoe just to get to class
English lessons in a jungle clearing as
teenagers study for future jobs in the
service industry but it's hard to
concentrate on these makeshift
classrooms and teachers don't even have
the basic Educational Tools
we want to open up higher education but
getting access to the internet and books
for the library is still difficult we're
trying to solve this
for most children in this area even a
basic education and plans for the future
seem a long way off the best they can
hope for is a hot meal and if they're
lucky a full stomach Tony Chang Al
Jazeera